the world has been looking for a malaria
vaccine to be used in africa
for over a hundred years now
malaria being
potentially the largest killer of humans
on this planet over history remains a
major cause of disease and death in
africa
the announcement that we have a first
generation vaccine
with moderate efficacy but that can save
hundreds of thousands of lives when
deployed together with the other
interventions we have is a
scientific breakthrough
it's a public health historical
event that for the first time a malaria
vaccine can be safely and efficaciously
deployed to save lives of african
children you said african children are
they
mostly the victims of malaria the brunt
of the disease is carried by
africa
and within africa it's young african
children and pregnant women but mostly
young african children the ones that
suffer the most severe consequences of
the disease
and die the world has been focused on a
pandemic i mean how much of an impact
has that had on the research and
development of this vaccine
altogether probably less than 1 billion
dollars have been invested in this and
any other malaria vaccine over the last
30 years
just imagine the comparison of what the
world has invested in covet vaccines
over the last 12 months
i think it sends a very powerful message
both to other vaccine developers
but to the broader international
community particularly in this
post-covet 19 era
where we cannot leave anyone behind we
should not be leaving anyone behind and
most importantly we should not be
leaving african children
deprived of the powers of science and
technology developing effective vaccines
that can provide them
an outlook of a of a of a safe
uh future ahead of them i think we are
at a turning point you were dealing with
a parasite that's what made it more
difficult than trying to evolve for
example a coveted vaccine this is orders
of magnitude more complex than a covet
vaccine or
any of the other vaccines we have today
it is really
comparing a a bicycle with the with the
space shuttle the the the orders of
complexity are are in those scales and
the world had never had a vaccine
against a human parasite not just
against malaria against any human
parasite
what impact will this vaccine roll out
have
on
africa
together with other interventions a
malaria vaccine will help us save tens
of thousands of lives hundreds of
thousands of lives
prevent
millions of cases and help us
regain momentum in the fight
against malaria it is of massive global
significance